[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hi everybody.
I'm Laurence Moroney for
"The Developer Show,"
and I'm at the TensorFlow
Developer Summit.
And it's my honor
to have Anitha here.
Anitha, you gave a
wonderful keynote today.
Thank you so much.
ANITHA VIJAYAKUMAR: Thanks
a lot for having me here.
It's awesome.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That
was a great keynote.
ANITHA VIJAYAKUMAR:
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
you actually kicked off
the day, right?
ANITHA VIJAYAKUMAR: Yes.
This time I had the opportunity
to kick off the day.
And yeah, it was very exciting
to see so many people.
And they're growing,
so it's awesome.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You got
us off to a great start.
And I really love
that you were starting
by talking about a revolution
in machine learning.
So can you tell us a
little more about that?
ANITHA VIJAYAKUMAR:
So I don't know
if you've heard Sundar
or other people who've
compared this to as big a
discovery as electricity.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
And the industrial
revolution, right?
ANITHA VIJAYAKUMAR:
Industrial revolution.
So it's really
fascinating for us
to be a part of this revolution.
And Google is at the forefront,
building things ground up--
the hardware, software,
the whole stack--
and making it
accessible to everyone.
And that's our main thing.
So we want to see what
people can do with this.
We want to see what new
applications they come up with.
And it's really exciting.
It is a revolution for sure.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Definitely.
Now, you showed some
really cool things,
like planet discovery
and health care.
Do you have any favorites
that you've been working on
or your team has
been working on?
ANITHA VIJAYAKUMAR:
Health care is
one of the area that's
really a favorite of mine.
My mother-in-law is
an ophthalmologist.
And so when I tell
her that machines
can do some part of her
job, she doesn't believe me.
LAURENCE MORONEY: No, no, no.
No they can't.
No, no, no.
ANITHA VIJAYAKUMAR: And I
really want to prove her wrong.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
You're getting closer.
Have you proven it yet?
ANITHA VIJAYAKUMAR: Yeah,
we you are getting closer.
And diabetic retinopathy, like
what Jeff said, is awesome.
We're able to cure causes
for that, especially if it's
a preventable, treatable cause.
And you don't have this many
trained ophthalmologists,
so this is going to make a
huge impact to a lot of people.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's
part of the tragedy,
that this is preventable, but
there just aren't enough people
out there to prevent it.
So if we can scale out
through machine learning--
ANITHA VIJAYAKUMAR: Yes.
And you have so
many mobile devices.
They are ubiquitous.
They are everywhere.
And they have the power
today which is probably
much more than what
people had when
they landed a man on the moon.
So you could do amazing
things with these devices.
And machine learning
will enable that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now,
you started your keynote
talking about revolution
in machine learning,
and then ended your keynote
with saying TensorFlow
makes all this possible.
And it really does, doesn't it?
ANITHA VIJAYAKUMAR: Yes.
Each one of those examples
were powered by TensorFlow.
And our goal is to make
it open, transparent,
accept contribution
from everybody,
and help solve challenging and
real problems for all of us.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
And so if I'm a developer and I
want to get my arms around this
and get started with it, what
advice would you give me?
ANITHA VIJAYAKUMAR:
So I didn't start
in machine learning as well.
I did other things and now
came to machine learning.
So I think there are a
lot of opportunities here.
We just launched the Machine
Learning Crash Course.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
The crash course.
ANITHA VIJAYAKUMAR: The MLCC.
That's a really nice
one to play with.
And we have something
called TensorFlow for Poets.
So even if you're a poet, you
can go program in TensorFlow.
That's the logic.
So you should check those out.
There are lots of
courses online.
YouTube has so many videos.
I think those should--
if you want to do it,
there are enough and more.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And we have
a great new YouTube channel,
YouTube.com/TensorFlow.
ANITHA VIJAYAKUMAR:
Yes, absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I've
got to plug it, sorry.
So thank you so much, Anitha.
And thanks everybody.
This is "The Developer Show"
at the TensorFlow Summit.
If you've got any
questions for me
or if you have any
questions for Anitha,
just please leave them
in the comments below.
And thanks for watching.
ANITHA VIJAYAKUMAR:
Thank you for having me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]